new reports suggest that the Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince is the mysterious
buyer of a rare Leonardo da Vinci
painting the Salvator Mundi painting set
in our studio before it was sold at
auction we love having this video for
record 450 million dollars it was a very
special day I have to say when it was
here in the studio in the corner the
Wall Street Journal reports that Prince
Mohammed bin Salman used a proxy to buy
the masterpiece
while Holly Williams has just returned
from Saudi Arabia she's with us in
Istanbul with more on how this purchase
could reflect the princes vision for the
kingdom Holly good morning good morning
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman is
known as a fan of the Arts and as a
reformer but this reported purchase
which we cannot independently confirm
comes as he also leads a corruption
crackdown on Saudi Arabia's wealthy
elite Crown Prince Mohammed is King
Salman anointed successor in his
oil-rich Islamic Kingdom the reported
purchase of a painting for nearly half a
billion dollars might not look good in
the midst of leading a corruption
crackdown though there's no suggestion
the money was ill-gotten its pocket
change compared to the staggering misuse
of public funds revealed by economy
minister mohammed al to a jury 20
billion dollar-a-year that billion
dollars a year has been lost to
corruption its negligence its
overspending al to a jury took over as
Minister after the last one was
reportedly detained for corruption last
month one of more than 300 rounded up
for questioning some held in a luxury
hotel apparently including several
members of the Saudi royal family
critics say that what the crown prince
is doing with this corruption crackdown
is sidelining or silencing his rivals is
you think he needs that he's the most
popular leader we come across you know
in our history that might be true but
criticizing the crown prince would be
downright dangerous I went to Wales it's
only in London that Saudi dissident
Hunnam al dasari dares to make videos
satirizing the Saudi government
he says Saudi corruption is much bigger
than the current clampdown
speaking up your mind this is a crime in
Saudi Arabia people being has
disappeared and being charged for tweets
those detained in this corruption
crackdown will be forced to hand over
part of their fortunes
it's thought those payments could total
up to 100 billion dollars biana
you're the timing of that purchase does
raise eyebrows though when the talk is
about transparency and corruption but I
think it's time for us to take a trip to
the Louvre if that's where it saw yeah
how about that - Brian our ep what do
you think the Louvre in Abu Dhabi Saint
Abu Dhabi that's right Brian said me no
speaking Fionna who very expensive Holly
Williams our thanks to you